[संगीत]
यह ए गया
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग तू जो वेलकम तू
सिक्स ऑफ फ्री कैप्सूल कोर्स
मुझे पता चल जाएगी
प्लीज कमेंट में बता दीजिए
ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू
क्या चल रहा है की कुछ कमांड से रिलेटेड
चीज चल रही है तो क्या ऐसा ग रहा है की बर
हो रहे हैं की अभी थोड़ा सा टॉपिक चेंज
करना चाहिए फिर वापस कमांड पर आना चाहिए
ऐसा किसी को ग रहा था एक बार कमेंट में
बताना
हो सकता है की कंटिन्यू हर सेशन में कमांड
कमांड रहेंगे तो
सही से समझ में भी ना आए और परम प्रॉब्लम
भी हो
एक बार बता दीजिए आप लोग
आज नहीं आज कंटिन्यू करते हैं कुछ कमांड
चेंज करते हैं इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक पहले बता
देता हूं की यूजर मैनेजमेंट रहेगा ग्रुप
मैनेजमेंट रहेगा और उसके बाद फरदर कुछ
क्लासेस में और आपकी फाइल सिक्योरिटी
रहेगी और परमीशंस को कैसे मैनेज किया जाता
है उसके बाद फिर से वापस आएंगे कमेंट्स के
ऊपर ताकि आप लोग पीछे से इन कमांड्स को एक
बार रिवाइज करके प्रैक्टिस कर पाव क्लियर
करवाओ जितने भी कमांड सभी बच्ची हुई है और
जितनी मुझे बतानी है वो सभी लाइनेक्स
एडमिन सबके लिए बहुत ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
है
क्योंकि आपको आगे लेने से एनवायरनमेंट में
भी कम करोगे या रियल सर्वर पर कम करोगे तो
हर कोई लाइनेक्स एडमिन इनको उसे करता है
यह करता है इनके बगैर कम चल ही नहीं सकता
लाइनेक्स एनवायरनमेंट में
और क्योंकि इसके सारे टास्क बेस है
क्योंकि हर कमांड का अपना एक रोल है हर
कमांड अपने रोल के हिसाब से ही कम करती है
जो आपको टास्क परफॉर्म करनी है वो हर एक
कमांड के अकॉर्डिंग डिफाइंड है क्योंकि एक
कमांड एक पॉइंट के बाद अपनी लिमिटेशंस में
ए जाति है उसके बाद दूसरी कमांड उसको टेक
और कर लेती है
तो फिर आज हम पढ़ने वाले हैं कट कमांड एक
अब कमांड अगर टाइम रात हो एक और कमांड
पढ़ेंगे एडरवाइज हम दो कमांड फिर
स्टार्ट करते हैं
तो कट कमांड बेसिकली युटुब कट अन्य
रिकॉर्ड्स यूजिंग करैक्टर और फाइल्स फ्रॉम
अन्य फाइल और फ्रॉम अन्य कमांड
आउटपुट से चाय वी फाइल का आउटपुट हो चाहे
वो आपको किसी भी कमांड आउटपुट फोटो आप
उसमें मां चाहे आपको क्या करना है किसी भी
फील्ड को कट करना है और इस के अकॉर्डिंग
आपको अपना आउटपुट देखना है स्क्रीन के ऊपर
प्रिंट करना है और किसी फाइल के अंदर से
करना है तो उसके लिए कट कमांड बहुत अच्छे
कमांड है तो उसका सिंटेक्स क्या है उसके
बड़े में आपको बताता हूं
इंटेक्स उसका है आप उसे करते हैं बट उसके
बाद आप उसे करेंगे ऑप्शन
ऑप्शन उसके बाद आप उसे करते हैं फाइल का
नाम
फाइल नाम या दूसरा तरीका क्या है एक और
तरीके से आपको उसे कर सकते हैं
कमांड नाम
1 मिनट कमेंट कर दीजिए मुझे
उसके बाद पाइप सिंबल और कट उसके बाद
सिंपली ब्लैक का उसे कर सकते हो आप
ऑप्शन
अब यह दो तरीके हैं
इन दोनों को कैसे उसे कर सकते हैं आपको
अच्छे से दिखे
अब क्या होता है
ऑप्शन बोल सकते हैं फ्लैग बोल सकते हैं
एक तो होता है
ओके सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस अब बात करते हैं
जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं उसका मतलब क्या है
कट बाय कैरक्टर्स आप क्या कर सकते हो
कैरेक्टर भाई कैरेक्टर आपको क्या कर सकते
हैं उसको फाइल में से जो भी आपका डाटा है
या आपका जो कमांड का आउटपुट है उसको क्या
कर सकते हो आप आ कट कर सकते हैं एक और
ऑप्शन उसे कर सकते हैं हम इसके साथ
आईफोन है ऑप्शन
इसका मतलब है कट बाय
यह कैसे करते हैं मैं दिखता हूं फील्ड का
मतलब क्या होता है उसके बाद बात करते हैं
डिफाइन डी
एम
में कुछ भी हो सकता है कोई भी सिंबल एवं
आपका कोमा आपके सेमी कोलोन
आपका डॉलर
@
कुछ भी हो सकता है
इंडिकेशन देता है की मेरा पहले फिल्म
डिफाइन कर पता है की मुझे कहां तक कट करना
है एडरवाइज इसको इसके लिए तो क्या की पूरा
पूरा एक ही फील्ड है अगर आपने फाइल का नाम
दिया है कमांड दिया क्योंकि आपने टेलीविजन
नहीं किया
एग्जांपल जैसे मैंने कैट किया
पुरी लाइन है अब मुझे क्या करना है इसमें
से जो मनीष है इसमें से ओनली मनीष चाहिए
मुझे ओन्ली महेश चाहिए या मुझे ओनली एम
करैक्टर चाहिए पहले मुझे ओनली एम कैरेक्टर
चाहिए तो मैं कैसे निकलेगा तो एक तो तरीका
ये है की मैं कहूंगा कट करता हूं
उसने क्या कर दिया कट कर दिया और प्रिंट
कर दिया
था तो उसके लिए आपको पता है की हम मल्टीपल
कमांड्स को आपस में जोड़ सकते हैं वो कैसे
कर सकते हैं मैंने क्या किया
मुझे मैंने क्या किया तेल कमांड का मैंने
उसे किया तेल कमांड हिफिन 2 लास्ट के दो
हिट हंटर अब इसने क्या किया की लास्ट की
जो दो लाइन थी इस का आउटपुट आपकी स्क्रीन
पे प्रिंट आउट करके दिया है अब मुझे क्या
करना है की अब पूरा ही करैक्टर चाहिए मुझे
ओनली मुझे क्या करना है एक बार मैं आपको
फिर से स्क्रीन पर शो करके दिखा देता हूं
कैट करके दिखा देता हूं कैट कैट ये रहा आप
मुझे क्या करना है की ये पूरा मनीषा या
मनीष नाम चाहिए मुझे अपने स्क्रीन पर ओनली
इसी करैक्टर को कट करना है तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा ये भी मैं कर सकता हूं तो ये क्या
है काउंट करते हैं हम वन तू थ्री फोर फाइव
सिक्स टोटल सिक्स है तो कैसे कर सकता हूं
चलेगा
ए को कट कर दिया इस वाले को लेकिन जो हमें
चाहिए
को तेल लगा सकते हैं तो हमारे कम करेगा अब
मुझे क्या करना है नहीं मुझे क्या करना है
की ये जो एम चाहिए मुझे इसमें से और एम
चाहिए मतलब फर्स्ट और थ्री चाहिए ये भी
मैं कर सकता हूं कैसे
सिंपली वन और उसके बाद क्या करूंगा मैं
कोमा उसे करूंगा उसके बाद थ्री फर्स्ट फोर
तो ये का गया एम और एन कोई इसने क्या किया
आपकी स्क्रीन पर प्रिंट करके दिखा दिया यह
था की आप किसी भी करैक्टर को कैसे कट कर
सकते हो किसी भी फाइल के अंदर से किसी भी
कमांड के अंदर से
अब एक चीज दिखाओ
और भी अच्छा आउटपुट देखने के लिए मैं
कहूंगा मैं मैंने क्या किया
उसके बाद इसमें से ग्राफ किया हिफिन
ब्लू एग्जैक्ट मैच चाहिए
ऐसे भी कर सकता हूं
अब सदा के तो अकेला सदी ए गया अगर इसमें
से मुझे ओन्ली
कर सकता हूं अदर वाइस क्या कर सकता हूं
अगर मेरा इस टाइप का आउटपुट आता है
विदाउट इसके तब मैं बस क्या बहुत सारे
एचडी थे लेकिन क्या किया इतना ही मिलेगा
अगर मुझे यहां तक कट करना था यहां तक करना
पड़ेगा तो आप अच्छे से कर सकते हो अगर
मुझे ओन्ली डेस्क को कट करना होता तो क्या
करूंगा मुझे
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 यहां तो 12 13
14 15 16
कैसे कट कर सकते हैं
अभी क्या की डिस्क अपडेट
इसको भी हम कट कर सकते हैं और इसको भी
फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हैं
यह तरीका
उसे कर सकते हो आपके मशीन में अब बात करते
हैं
की फील्ड कैसे कट करना है अब इसमें अगर
मैं एग्जांपल लेट हूं की यह एक फील्ड है
यह एक फील्ड है और यह अपने आप में एक
फील्ड है
अगर आप उसे करोगे तो विदाउट डिलीटर आप
उसको उसे नहीं कर सकते कैसे मैंने क्या
किया
इसमें से मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं फील्ड
वन कौन सा
ये वाला सचिन वाला यह मनीष मनीष वाला मैं
कैसे देख सकता हूं सिंपली मैंने किया फाइव
सिंपल उसे किया है उसके बाद कट किया और
दें एफ वन
अब इसमें क्या किया की सभी को प्रिंट आउट
कर दिया क्यों मैंने पहले ही बताया था
विदाउट डिलीटर आप इसको उसे नहीं कर सकते
क्योंकि यह बोलना है की जब तक आप मुझे कुछ
डिफाइन ही नहीं करोगे कुछ बताओगे नहीं की
आपका फील्ड कहां तक डिफाइन तो मेरे लिए तो
पूरा फील्ड है तो कैसे कर सकते हो आप
सिंपली आपको कोई पहले इसको क्या है
डायमीटर डिफाइन करना होगा वो कैसे करोगे
आईफोन दी उसके बाद आपको बताना होगा सिंगल
कोड दें डेलीमिटर मैंने बता दिया इसमें
आपका कलम है उसके बाद हिफिन f1 ठीक है
जितना भी क्या है कोलोन सेपरेटेड है उसका
यह है इसके लिए फील्ड वन हो गया जैसे
एफडी रिफ्रेश
के लिए फील्ड वन है अगर आपको फाइल तू
प्रिंट करना होता तो वो भी कर सकते हो
अगर आपको क्या करना फील्ड वन और आपको
प्रिंट करना है
प्रिंट आउट करके दिखा दिया
अगर आपको वन
तू थ्री
शो करके दिखाए था इस तरीके से आप जो कट
कमांड है के अलग-अलग फ्लैग को कैसे उसे कर
सकते हैं मैंने आपको दिखाए अब एक फाइल
होती है हमारे सामने मैं करता हूं कैट
स्लैश
लोग
होती है
क्योंकि यहां पर लोग हैं ही नहीं इसके
अंदर कोई बात नहीं अगर मैसेज देता हूं
मुझे क्या करना है
अब आपको क्या करना है की मुझे आपकी
स्क्रीन पर यह क्या है
किसी फाइल के अंदर से तो मैं कैसे कर सकता
हूं उसके लिए
वह लोग मैसेज उसके बाद में क्या करूंगा
लेटेस्ट फाइट चाहिए
मुझे
क्या करना है
अब स्पेस देने के लिए आपको इसके अंदर जो
सिंगल कॉटन के अंदर आपको एक स्पेस देना
होगा दें आपको
देना होगा दें यह फर्स्ट वाला चाहिए मुझे
उसके बाद सेकंड भी चाहिए
सेकंड भी चाहिए
टेंडर अब यह देखिए
यह टाइम यह डेट है कौन सा महीना था कौन सी
डेट थी कितने टाइम पर कौन सा यूजर था
जिसने हमारे सरवर को हिट किया तो यह
लेटेस्ट पाइप एंट्री होगी आप किसी को
फॉरवर्ड कर सकते हो की हां किसी ने बोला
की मुझे लेटेस्ट एंट्री चाहिए विथ यूजर
नाम कौन-कौन थे तो इस तरीके से आप कैसे कट
करके आपको दे सकते हो अब क्या होता है
की ये भी एक कुछ हद तक आपके ऑपरेशन को
आसानी से परफॉर्म कर शक्ति है यहां पर कुछ
लिमिटेशंस आई हैं जब आपको दिल्ली में
डिफाइन करने होते हैं क्योंकि
मैं आपको दिखता हूं कमांड होती है
अब देखो यहां पर
स्पेस
ज्यादा है
ठीक है
मैंने क्या किया
उसके बाद सिंपली
मैं कर रहा हूं कट उसके बाद
आईफोन अप आईफोन अप
वन दे दिया मैंने सिंपली अब फील्ड वन तो
मैं आसानी से कट कर लिया अब प्रॉब्लम
यहां पर आएगी यहां पर लिमिटेड
[संगीत]
की अब
तो इस कैसे में क्या होता है की अगर आप
सही से अपना डाली में जो दिल्ली मी है
बनाने में कैपेबल नहीं हो बना नहीं सकते
कट कमांड के साथ आप कट कमांड के साथ तो
सही से ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म नहीं कर का रहे इस
कैसे में ए ब्लू के कमांड कम में आई है अब
ए ब्लू के पास ये रहा नाम लिख देता हूं
आपके सामने अब मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड है
सेल्स स्क्रिप्टिंग में ये जितने भी कमांड
है अभी चल रहा हूं बहुत अच्छे से कम आई है
अब अब कमांड क्या करती है की आ के कमांड
बोलती है की मेरे को आपको जो स्पेस है
मुझे आपको आप लोग मेरे को स्पेस डिफाइन
करने की जरूर नहीं है आप लोगों को
तो ठीक है तो अब यह कम आसन कैसे हुआ मैंने
सिंपली क्या किया बीएफ किया था आईफोन हा
किया
सकता हूं फाइव उसे किया अब कमांड उसके बाद
सिंगल कोड के अंदर अब इसके अंदर आपको क्या
करना है
ओपन और क्लोज इसके अंदर आपको क्या करना
पड़ता है आपका डिफाइन करना है जो प्रिंट्स
आप मुझे क्या करना है इसके अंदर प्रिंट
करना है सिंपली मुझे क्या करना है प्रिंट
पी आर आई एन टी प्रिंट उसके बाद मुझे
फील्ड अब मैं एक बार आपको दिखा देता हूं
इसके लिए क्या है
ये तू है ये थ्री है यह फोर है यह फाइव है
तो आप सिंपली उसे करोगे
फर्स्ट फील्ड को शो कर दिया अगर आपको
सेकंड को देखना है
डॉलर वन की जगह
कितनी इजी कम कर देंगे कट कमांड में आपको
सोचना पद रहा था की हिफिन दी के साथ मुझे
कितना स्पेस देना पड़ेगा मुझे क्या डिफाइन
है सिंपली उसे फेस को अपने आप एडजस्ट कर
लिया ऑटोमेटेकली काउंट कर लिया इतनी आसानी
से आपको आउटपुट स्क्रीन पर शो कर दिया अब
मुझे क्या करना था अगर मेरी डीएफ आईफोन हा
कमांड है और मुझे क्या करना है मुझे देखना
है की फाइल सिस्टम उसका साइज और वो कहां
पर माउंट है आगे ये तीन चीज मुझे देख लेने
तो मैं कैसे देख सकता हूं सिंपली दी या
फाइव वन हा उसके बाद अब प्रिंट मुझे क्या
करना है
मुझे दूसरा मुझे क्या चाहिए
123456 चाहिए
कौन सा किस फील्ड का है ओके तो अगर मुझे
अपना आउटपुट सही से अरेंज ढंग से चाहिए तो
मैं उसे कर सकता हूं कैसे
अब यहां पर टाइप के साथ में उसे करता है
कमांडो
क्या करते हैं अरेंज कर देगा आप सिंपली
हिट है अब ये इसने क्या कर दिया देखो
3 है इस तरीके से अब कमांडो को आप उसे कर
सकते हैं
आपका बहुत कम आसन कर दिया है इसने ये ब्लू
के कमांड ने अब जैसे की मेरा बीएफ हा है
एक ओके
उसके अब कमांड को उसे कर रहा हूं सिंगल को
करली ड्रेस
25% आपके स्क्रीन पे शो कर दिया
तो अब मुझे एक कम कीजिए आप लोगों के लिए
यहां पर भी एक लास्ट वाला टॉर्च किसी ने
की यानी आप लोगों को मैंने बताया था एक
प्रैक्टिस क्वेश्चन दिया था किसी ने कमेंट
भी नहीं किया और ग्रुप में भी किसी ने
नहीं किया
करना है की मुझे मैंने आपके सामने इतना कम
आसन कर देखिए मैंने 25 परसेंटेज निकाल के
लिया है इस कमांड से अब मुझे यहां पर क्या
करना है की मुझे आउटपुट चाहिए यही बट मुझे
इसमें परसेंटेज नहीं चाहिए ओन्ली 25% ओनली
25 चाहिए स्क्रीन के ऊपर
तो यह कैसे आएगा
हमें
कमेंट में भेज देनी है कितने लोगों ने
किया नहीं किया
जो हमारा प्रोफाइल
डी आंसर विद स्क्रीनशॉट आप भेज सकते हो
दोबारा बता देता हूं की मैंने अपने
स्क्रीन पर 25% शो किया है इस कमांड का
उसे करते हुए लेकिन मुझे क्या करना है की
मुझे अपने आउटपुट में इस 25% में से ओनली
₹25 चाहिए ओन्ली फिट करता हूं जो आपकी
स्क्रीन पे दिखाई दे रहा है तो मुझे ये
चाहिए कैसे आएगा
25 आएगा तो वो कमांड आप लोग मुझे कमेंट
में
भेजोगे अब बात करते हैं
कंटिन्यू आगे बढ़ाने से पहले क्या करता
हूं आप लोगों को एक चीज बताने भूल गया
स्टार्टिंग मुझे बताने की आप लोगों को
मिस आउट हो गया की आज हमने ग्रुप में
डिस्कशन किया था तो आप क्या करोगे जो
हमारी युटुब चैनल है
जिसमें आप अभी लॉगिन हो रहा अब इसके नीचे
क्या है की यहां पर ये इंस्टाग्राम का पेज
है ये लिंकडइन पेज है ये ट्विटर पेज है ये
फेसबुक पेज है ये टेलीग्राम पेज है और ये
वेबसाइट तो आपको क्या करना है की लिंकडइन
पेज पर क्लिक करना है सिंपली और यहां पर
आपको क्या है लॉगिन करना है आप अपनी आईडी
बनाई है और यहां पर इसको फॉलो कर लीजिए
इसको जितने भी अनाउंसमेंट रहेगी
और जो हमने स्टार्ट किया है की जितने भी
क्लासेस होगी यह सभी का क्या है यहां पर
स्क्रीनशॉट के साथ हमने डाला हुआ है लिंक
और आपको क्या करना है की जैसे आपने क्लास
वन कंप्लीट कर लिया क्लास तू कंप्लीट कर
लिया क्लास थ्री कंप्लीट कर लिया तो प्लीज
आपने क्लास
देवन में क्लास दे तू में
टॉपिक थे आप उसको कमेंट आउट करके बता
दीजिए सो डेट की बाकी लोगों को भी पता चला
की चल क्या रहा है जो भी कमेंट करना है आप
इस पे कर सकते हो जो भी आप लोगों ने पढ़ा
है जो भी नहीं है जैसे की दे वन पे बहुत
लोगों ने कमेंट किया है जो हम पढ़ सकते
हैं अगर पढ़ पाएंगे तो उसके लिए लॉगिन
करना पड़ेगा मुझे
तो आप ऐसे हमारे लोग इस पे है लिंकडइन पेज
पर जाइए और जैसे की जी दिन की क्लास खत्म
हो जाति है जैसे
ही खत्म हो जाएगी तो आप उधर जाइए कमेंट
करके बता दीजिए की आज के तो जो डेट शिक्षा
उसमें आप लोगों ने क्या-क्या शिखा
क्या-क्या टॉपिक हुआ था और कैसा होता है
वो कमेंट में बता सकते हो आप लोग दूसरा
क्या होता है की एक और है हमारा
इंस्टाग्राम पेज है इंस्टाग्राम पेज पर भी
से चल रहा है तो उसमें भी आपको क्या करना
है
यह रवि क्या की मैं लॉगिन नहीं किया है तो
अगर आप लॉगिन करोगे तो इस पेज को फॉलो कर
लीजिए तो इन दोनों जगह पर ही आपको हर चीज
के लिए अनाउंसमेंट मिलेगी पर पर योर
फ्यूचर बेनिफिट की जो भी हम प्लेन कर रहे
होंगे आप लोगों को लेकर जो खासकर जो हमारे
साथ कंटिन्यू बने हुए हैं जिनके लिए हमने
कुछ सोचा होगा दिमाग में तो और कुछ भी
अनाउंसमेंट रहेगा वो इन दो पेज पे आपको
देखने को मिलेगा तो प्लीज थोड़ा सा 5 मिनट
निकालिए जाइए और इनको फॉलो कीजिए फॉलो
करने के बाद और ऑफ डी क्लास आप जाइए
दो मिनट लगेगी आपको जान के बाद आप क्या
करना है आपको उसे पर्टिकुलर
वीडियो के नीचे कमेंट कीजिए की जो भी आपने
शिखा जो भी पढ़ा की बाकी लोगों की हेल्प
हो जाए लोगों को पता चल सके की हां किस दे
में क्या कंटेंट था क्या पटाया गया क्या
डिस्कस किया गया तो आप लोगों को पता था
बाकी लोगों को पता चलेगा की
हां ये जीवन में था यह दे तू में था ये दे
थ्री में था जो भी आपकी कमेंट्स आप वहां
पर जाकर कर सकते हैं एक छोटी सी
अनाउंसमेंट की आप लोगों के लिए
कंटिन्यू करता हूं अपनी कमांड के साथ
ओके
दें तो अभी हम क्या थे की आपको पता चल गया
होगा की यह टास्क आपको क्या करना है
तो इधर भी आप वह टास्क क्या कर सकते हो
कमेंट करके दिखा सकते हो
स्क्रीनशॉट के साथ भेज सकते हो की हमने
हमें यह प्रैक्टिस क्वेश्चन मिला था और
हमने यह कर दिया है ये इसकी कमांड है
तो ये भी अच्छी चीज है तो अब हम क्या करते
हैं की आपको
कंटिन्यू कमांड है
जो आपके इंटरनेट की डिटेल शो करती है
नेटवर्क की कौन-कौन से एनआइसीएफ की मशीन
में लगी है और किसका क्या ए जाता है
जीरो और एक लोकल एड्रेस है
मुझे क्या करना है इसमें सिर्फ मुझे ये जो
आईपीएल लेना मुझे इसको क्या करना है
देखना है तो मुझे यही देखना तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा तो सिंपल है मैं क्या करूंगा
उसे कर लिया ऐसे मल्टीपल कमांड का उसे कर
सकते हो जिससे आपको पता चला की अभी तक
जितने कमांड उसे किया वो कितना हेल्प कर
रही है आपका आपको कम करने के लिए चिप 500
ब्लू उसके बाद आई नेट क्योंकि नेट चाहिए
मुझे तो मैंने हिट अंदर किया अब मेरा
आउटपुट नैरो डॉ हो गया पहले तो क्या था एक
कमांड का आउटपुट इतना था अब इतना स्क्रीन
पे प्रिंट हो रहा है नेट के लिए दो चीज
हैं दो आई नीड है मुझे तो 192168 वाला
चाहिए तो थोड़ा सा अब क्या है की मैं इसके
ऊपर चलाऊंगा अपनी अब कमांड
उसके बाद प्रिंट करना है और सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है डॉलर कौन सा चाहिए तू चाहिए
आपको वन तो चाहिए नहीं अगर ओनली चाहिए वन
चाहिए तो वो भी वन लिखोगे या वन उसके बाद
दें डॉलर तू वन और तू अब दोनों प्रिंट आउट
कर दिया अब स्क्रीन के सामने अब आपकी
स्क्रीन पे ए जाएंगे आई नेट
192.168145
ठीक है इसको क्या करना है थोड़ा सा और अगर
आपको सिंगल ओनली आई नीड 192 वाला चाहिए तो
वो भी कर सकते हो कैसे करोगे उसके लिए आप
क्या करोगे
बनाना चाहता हूं वो भी मैं कर सकता हूं वो
मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं जैसे की मैं क्या
करूंगा
यह मेरी इतनी कमांड है तो मैं वह इसके साथ
एक चीज उसे कर सकता हूं पहले मुझे इसको
हटा देता हूं अब यहां पर एक पैरामीटर
उसके बाद क्या है वो चीज यहां पर डिफाइन
करेंगे जिससे आप इसको क्या कहना चाहते हो
सेपरेट करना चाहता हूं मैं सिंगल को के
अंदर वो चीज को डॉग जैसे मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं एक दो तीन
दोनों फील्ड को तो सिंपली उसके बाद
टाइप सिंबल
कोड
ग रहा है
आपको समझ में ए रहा होगा की हमने क्या
किया यहां पर अगर जैसे की अब यह तो था ठीक
है
मैं कैसे करूंगा ठीक है सिंपली अभी तक
करते हैं ऐसे ही करेंगे हमने क्या किया
कमांड को उसे किया उसके बाद फाइव सिंबल
उसके बाद अब किया दें सिंगल को उसके अंदर
पेरैंथेसिस
उसके बाद फ्रेंड किया और अरे
कर दिया
क्योंकि मैंने पहले ही बताया था जो अब
कमांड
करता है स्पेस के अलावा अगर आप किसी भी
फाइल को
देना चाहते हो उसको फिर डिफाइन करना था तो
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
तो अब इसके लिए मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा
ऑप्शन उसे होता है उसको बोलते हैं हम
हिफिन कैपिटल एफ दें
सिंगल सिंगल को
इसका स्पेस रहेगा
अगर आपको अच्छे से थोड़ा और
आउटपुट चाहिए तो सिंपली क्या है मैं क्या
करना तेल एड कर रहा हूं मैं हेड उसके बाद
दें
प्रॉब्लम
मेरा काफी अच्छा खूबसूरत
है इसमें क्या है रैंडम अभी हमने जो फील्ड
कट किया तो क्या हुआ उसमें क्या इसने क्या
किया की विदाउट स्पेस सेपरेट क्या कर दिया
इसको मर्ज कर दिया लेकिन कलम हिफिन ठीक है
इसमें क्या कलम कमांड का क्या है की ये
कलम में इस जो आउटपुट ए रहा है उसको अरेंज
करना है इसका मतलब ये है अगर आपको देखना
है ज्यादा सी ओ ल यू एम एन हिफिन हिफिन
हेल्प करके आप देख सकते हो इसको मां के
बड़े में आईफोन टी टेबल एक टेबल ग्रेट
करनी है
इसका मतलब क्या है
टेबल की फॉर्म में शो करना है इसका मतलब
है कलम हिप्नोटी जब भी आपको कोई अगर कमांड
से समझ में नहीं आते सिंपली कमांड का नाम
आईफोन
का मतलब किस फ्लैग का किस ऑप्शन का क्या
मतलब है क्या ये समझना छह रहा है इसमें सब
कुछ डिटेल में लिखा राहत है आप इसका उसे
कर सकते हैं
यह थी आपकी एक क के कमांड
अब आपको क्या करना है
मैंने बता दिया की ए ब्लू के कमांड और कट
कमांड को कैसे उसे करना है अब
ठीक है
आप इस को कंप्लीट कीजिए
अब बात करते हैं की
जीप और अनजिप कमांड के बड़े में
अब अगर हमें लाइनेक्स एनवायरनमेंट में
किसी भी फाइल को कंप्रेस या दी कंप्रेस
करना है तो कैसे करेंगे
वह हम सीखने हैं जैसे की मेरे एक फाइल है
यहां पर मैं अगर आपको एलएस करके दिखाऊं
डिमांड और टक्स अगर मैं इसको कैट करता हूं
सबको पता है डेमो टी एक्स टी करके मेरी
फाइल है
अगर मैं इसका साइज देखूंगा वायरलेस हाइपर
ल करके देखूं डिमांड और इंटर इसका साइज है
मेरा
फॉर्म में देखा हूं 1111
टेंडर इससे मैं करता हूं उसके अंदर
ओके
फाइल को शेर करना है किसी के पास अब उसका
साइज बहुत ज्यादा है बट
उसे साइज के अकॉर्डिंग
फाइल को अपनी मशीन में रख सकते हैं उसके
बाद भेज सकते हैं एडरवाइज क्या होता है कई
बार क्या है बहुत साड़ी बहुत सारे कम चल
रहा होता आपके एनवायरनमेंट में और कुछ ऐसी
फाइलें हैं जो काफी टाइम से उसे में नहीं
हो रही लेकिन इंपॉर्टेंट है उनको डिलीट
नहीं कर सकते तो क्या करोगे
तीनों कमांड के बड़े में बताऊंगा अकेला ही
कमांड के बड़े में बताऊंगा तो जैसे की इस
फाइल का साइज है
कमांड होती है और सिंपली डेमो
तो देखिए यहां पर
इसका मतलब ये कंप्रेस्ड फाइल है अगर हम
इसका साइज देखेंगे कैसे देखेंगे
जड़ कैट जड़ कैट उसके बाद उसे फाइल का नाम
डेमो
कर दिया
अनकंप्रेस नहीं हुई तो अगर मुझे इसको
अनकंप्रेस करना है तो कैसे करूंगा उसके
लिए कमांड होती है मेरी
अजीब करना है कंप्रेस अनकंप्रेस करना है
नहीं कंप्रेस करना है तो कैसे हैं उसके
लिए होती है
अगर मैं क्या करता है
बी
जीप आया ठीक है
थोड़ा सा कम करेगा लेकिन क्या की छोटी
फाइल में एक इतना ज्यादा डिफरेंस आपको
देखने को नहीं मिलेगा लेकिन इसकी एलसीएम
कैसे कर सकते हैं कंप्रेस वो मैं दिखता
हूं
सिंपली और फाइल का नाम डेमो डॉट टी एक्स
टी
अब इसमें भी क्या कर दिया उसको
जीप कर दिया कंप्रेस कर दिया अगर हम इसका
साइज देखेंगे
टेंडर अब इसका साइज
कंप्रेशन टेक्निक का उसे करता है लेकिन
इसका एक्सटेंशन क्या है bz2 अगर आपको इसके
अंदर के कंटेंट को कंप्रेस्ड फाइल कंटेंट
को देखना है तो कैट कमांड से तो आप देख ही
नहीं सकते अगर और ऑब्जेक्ट कमांड से भी
नहीं देख सकते जो हमने लास्ट कमांड में
उसे किया था जो डॉट जी स जिसका एक्सटेंशन
था उसके लिए उसे किया था लेकिन बिजनौर तू
वाले एक्शन के लिए के लिए अगर आपको कंटेंट
को उसे देखना है उसके अंदर के जीप फॉर्मेट
में थे उसके लिए कमांड होती है बी स कैट
उसके बाद हम उसे करते हैं उसका फाइल का
नाम डेमो
यह ओपन करके दिखा दिया एक और कमांड होती
है
देखो आप इसको स्क्रॉल डॉ आराम से कर सकें
इसमें क्या एक साथ में पूरा आउटपुट शो कर
दिया था अब ये क्या है आराम-आराम से पेज
बाय पेज बाय आप क्या करते प्रोग्राम करते
रहो और पढ़ने रहो फाइल को अभी मैं क्या अब
मैं क्विड कर देता हूं
अगर आपको क्या करना है इसको दी कंप्रेस
करना है मतलब करना है उसके लिए ऐसा नहीं
की लास्ट में जो गंजी कमांड उसे की थी वो
उसे कर सकते नहीं इसके लिए जो कमांड होती
है अगर हम आपको गंजेब करके दिखता भी हूं
गंजी और डेमो रोटी एक्स टी
अभी इसने क्या
कोई कमांड उसे करनी पड़ेगी जिसका नाम है
फिर से वापस ए जाएगी
यह पुरी फाइल है अब अभी तक मैंने क्या
किया
10 15 20 फाइल है उनको कंप्रेस करना है एक
ही फाइल के अंदर और दे कंप्रेस करना है
उसे फाइल से वो कैसे कर सकते हैं तो इन दो
कमांड की हेल्प से वो कम हम नहीं कर सकते
उसके लिए कमांड उसे होती है जिसका नाम है
अब जैसे मेरे पास दो फाइल है अगर मैं एलएस
करके दिखता हूं डेमो
फाइल में क्रिएट करता हूं सैंपल
है क्या
तार का मतलब होता है
कमांड के अंदर तो हिफिन सी का मतलब होता
है क्रिएट अगर मैं वो जूम कर देता हूं
आईफोन सी का मतलब है क्रिएट आईफोन बी
वर्बोस मोड वर्सेस का मतलब मतलब ये होता
है की आप अपने जो भी कम हो रहा है
कंप्रेशन वाला हूं वहां पे स्क्रीन पे
आपको देखने को मिले हाइपर उसके बाद एफ उसे
कर सकते हैं एफ का मतलब फाइल नाम अब मुझे
उसे फाइल का नाम देना है जिसके अंदर इन
साड़ी फाइल को मैं कंप्रेस करना चाहता हूं
तो उसका नाम देना चाहता हूं मैं पी आर ए
सी टी आई सी प्रैक्टिस
डॉट स्ट्रक्चर
ऐसे एनपीएस सैंपल रोटी एक मेरी है
जिनको मैं इसके अंदर कंप्रेस करना चाहता
हूं फिर से बताता हूं सी का मतलब होता है
क्रिएट बी का मतलब वर्बोस अप का मतलब फाइल
उसे फाइल का नाम जिसके अंदर यहां पर वो
फाइलें दिया जाता है सिंपली मैं क्या करता
हूं की टेंडर कर दिया तो इसने क्या किया
अब जो डेमो 120 एक्सेस स्क्रीन पर जो
आउटपुट शो करेगा और किसकी वजह से शो कर
रहा है वी की वजह से वर्ब्स मोड की वजह से
अगर मैं एलएस करता हूं हिफिन ल करता हूं
तो देखिए यहां पर प्रैक्टिस डॉट तार नाम
से एक फाइल आपको देखने को मिलेगी अगर मैं
इसको नॉर्मली एलएस करता हूं तब भी आपको
देखने को मिलेगी अगर एलएस आईफोन
रखें हैं
अब क्या करते हैं
अगर आपको
किसी
[संगीत]
दूसरे स्टेशन
कर सकते हैं
मेरे पास
डेमो 128
अगर मैं क्या करता हूं
कैसे करूंगा
कैसे करूंगा जैसे
पहले फॉर्मेट में मुझे क्या करना है इसको
कंप्रेस करना है उसके बाद क्या करना चाहता
हूं
[संगीत]
rwd9
टेस्ट वनडे
डेमो डॉट
मेमोरी टेस्ट डॉट
टेक्स्ट और टेस्ट वन डॉट टेक्सटाइल
[संगीत]
कम कर रहा है
जड़ युद्ध करता हूं उसके बाद दें
डॉट जी
सिंटेक्स मिस्टेक
टेस्ट वनडे टेस्ट
ओके
कौन सी फाइल दे रहा हूं क्योंकि जो स
ऑप्शन है वो अप से पहले देना होगा तो अब
इसमें क्या करते हैं जीजे फॉर्मेट में भी
इसको क्या कर दिया
अब मैं एलएस करता हूं तो ये देखिए यहां पर
प्रैक्टिस जो तार है प्रैक्टिस टेस्ट डॉट
डॉट जी जो है
अब अगर मुझे किसी टीबीजी फॉर्मेट में भी
करना है तो मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं ता उसके
लिए मुझे फाइल क्रिएट करनी होगी
दें
टीबीजी फॉर्मेट दें उसके बाद
टेस्ट डॉट डॉट
करना बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है एवं अगर
आप लाइनेक्स एडमिन भी नहीं है अगर आप
साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर आपके लिए भी
बहुत ज्यादा है क्योंकि जब भी आप अपनी
मशीन में कोई भी पैकेट गिफ्ट हम से
डाउनलोड करोगे तो वह आपको गिफ्ट फॉर्मेट
में मिलेगा या अदर वाइस
वेबसाइट से डाउनलोड करो तब भी आपको क्या
का रहा था
उसके बाद मैन्युअल इंस्टॉलेशन करना होगा
अगर आपको अजीप करना ही नहीं आएगा तो कैसे
आप उसे फाइल को डाउनलोड या वो उसको
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं उसे कर सकते हैं
क्योंकि जीप जीप करने के लिए तार कमांड का
ही उसे किया जाएगा मेली अगर आप एवं कहानी
भी कम करोगे
तब भी आपको क्या है बहुत ज्यादा हेल्प
करने वाली है ये पैकेज इंस्टॉलेशन
अनइनस्टॉल में क्योंकि टायर कमांड ही वह
है जो आपको आपके फाइल को अजीब कर शक्ति है
इसलिए दिस इसे डी मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड
की आपको कैसे किसी को जब कर सकते हो कैसे
और जीप कर सकते हो बाकी भले ही वह इससे
पहले वाली जो कमांड है जो की रंजीत रंजीत
आपको याद करने की जरूर नहीं है अगर आपको
इधर से उधर कोई पैकेट शेर करना तो ठीक है
वो कंप्रेशन के लिए ज्यादा ही लेवल के
कंप्रेशन के लिए आप उसे कर सकते हैं
एडरवाइज आपको क्या करना है
किसी भी डाउनलोड पैकेट को अनपेक करने के
लिए किसी पैकेट को पैक करने के लिए आपको
बेसिकली तार कमांड का आना बहुत ही ज्यादा
जरूरी है तो अब मैं आपको दिखता हूं की जो
भी है टावर वाले पैकेट हैं उनको अंजीर
कैसे करते हैं लेकिन एक चीज है की अगर
आपको क्या करना है की जीप फाइल है और इस
के अंदर आप ये देखना चाहते हैं की कौन-कौन
सी फाइल इसके अंदर जीप की हुई है अजीप
किया हुए तो वो देख सकता हूं उसके लिए
कमांड होती है
क्या इस नाम की फाइल इसके जीप है या नहीं
स्पेस की वजह आप सर्च ही कर सकते हो उसके
लिए ऑप्शन होता है
उसे फाइल का नाम दें जो भी आपको सर्च करना
है कौन सी जैसे मुझे सर्च करना है डेमो वन
डॉट टी एक्स के नाम से फाइल है उसको सर्च
करना चाहता हूं इस बार तो हिट इंटर किया
तो इसमें शो कर दिया की हां इसके अंदर
डेमो 128 नाम की फाइल अगर मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं इसके अंदर सब्सक्राइब
फॉर्मेट में नहीं है नोट फाउंड इन आर का
फेलियर स्टेटस दिउ तू प्रीवियस एरर ओके अब
बात करते हैं की किसी भी फाइल को जब कोई
भी फाइल आपने जीप कर दी तो उसको अनचीफ
कैसे करेंगे तो उसके लिए कमांड यही है तार
उसे करेंगे क्योंकि आप उसे करोगे
टैक्स टैक्स का मतलब होता है
वाली फाइल इसने क्या कर दी क्योंकि मेरे
ऑलरेडी शो कर रहा था इसलिए आपको देखने को
मिल नहीं अदर वाइस ने क्या कर दिया उसको
कल ही दिया और ये तार के एंट्री मिलेगी अब
मैं एलएस करके दिखता हूं आईफोन ल करके
दिखता हूं फैक्ट्री डाटा
ओके तो इस तरीके से आप तार कमांड को उसे
कर सकते हो कैसे किसी भी फाइल को गिफ्ट
फॉर्मेट में क्रिएट कर सकते हो कैसे उसको
अजीब कर सकते हो कैसे हो
तो यह साड़ी चीज कमेंट के बड़े में
खत्म करते हैं क्योंकि इससे ज्यादा आगे
नहीं बढ़ेंगे मुझे लगता है की काफी कमांड
ही कमांड होगी कितने दिन से क्योंकि मुझे
मजा आता है लेकिन आप लोग क्या नए आप लोगों
को समझ में
कमांड रखना वो करना क्योंकि उसे नहीं कर
का रहे होंगे ना कहां पर उसे करने लेकिन
जब आप धीरे-धीरे
आज का इतना रखेंगे अब नेक्स्ट जोड़ी सेवन
रहेगा हमारा नया एक इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक से
स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं यूजर मैनेजमेंट
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है क्योंकि यूजर
को मैनेजमेंट करना भी बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी
है कैसे ग्रेट करते हैं कैसे डिलीट करते
हैं ग्रुप कैसे क्रिएट करते हैं पासवर्ड
कैसे एड करते हैं पासवर्ड के एक्सपायरी की
डेट कैसे ते करते हैं ये बहुत साड़ी चीज
तो नेक्स्ट क्लास ये साड़ी चीज
हम करने वाले हैं तो आपके लिए 5 मिनट है 5
मिनट का डॉ सेशन ओपन करके दिखाओ अगर कोई
डाउट है तो आप बता दीजिए कमेंट क्षेत्र
में मैं अभी आपके कमेंट देख रहा हूं
उसके बाद हम सेशन ओवर करेंगे
लेकिन उससे पहले मैं आपको बता देता हूं की
अभी
पांच से साथ मिनट के बाद क्या हो जाएगा
खत्म हो जाएगा तो प्लीज लिंकन पेज पर और
हमारे जो अभी आपको पहले बताया था
युटुब पर जाइए
और लिंकडइन पेज पर जाइए और इंस्टाग्राम
पेज को चाहिए वहां पर जाके अभी क्लास सेशन
और होने के 10 मिनट बाद ही या 15 मिनट बाद
के बाद क्या हो जाएगा हमारा बेसिक वाला
अपडेट हो जाएगा उसके अंदर लोगो और वीडियो
और आपको क्या करना है वहां जान के बाद उसे
पे कमेंट करना है की जो भी आज की क्लास
में आपने शिखा जो भी करना कमांड आपने सखी
और जो आपको समझ में आया वो चीज आप वहां पर
शेर कर सकते हो और एवं जो मैं आपको
प्रैक्टिस क्वेश्चन देता हूं वो भी आप
वहां पर जाकर शेर कर सकते हो की थिस वास
डी क्वेश्चन
दे फाइव है इसके तुरंत बाद जैसे सेशन और
होगा यहां पर बेसिक ए जाएगा
कमेंट करना है कमेंट करने के बाद
आप हमारी तरफ से करिए आप कुछ भी कर सकते
हैं ओके तो आप बताइए एक बार दीजिए
सैनिक कॉलोनी
आते डी रेट मतलब की मतलब की वहां पर
डिफाइन करते की मुझे यहां तक इस फील्ड को
मानना है यह एक लिमिटेड एक सिंबल डिफाइन
कर दिया जैसे की स्लाइस सीटीसी पर
डब्ल्यूडब्ल्यूई वाली फाइल थी
आपके सामने फ्लैश पीसी
मुझे क्या है मैंने क्या कर दिया ये इधर
से कला है कोलन को मैंने क्या बता दिया की
ये मेरा दिल्ली मी है ये भैया है उससे
पहले यह एक फील्ड वन है अब दिल्ली मी के
बीच में क्या है क्योंकि दिल्ली मी को
मैंने डेली मी डिफाइन किया तो उसके बीच
में क्या है की सारे फील्ड हैं अब हिफिन
अप का मतलब क्या है आपको फील्ड डिफाइन
करना है की अब दिल्ली में डिपेंड किया की
खोलना ओके तो इसके अकॉर्डिंग
फील्ड यह भी फील्ड है लेकिन यह एम्टी
फील्ड है ब्लैक है एक यह फील्ड है एक यह
फील्ड ओके तो इस तरीके से दिल्ली मी कम
करता है तो दिल्ली मी का सिंपल मतलब आप
वहां पर एक सिंबल डिफाइन कर रहे हैं एक
क्राइटेरिया डिपेंड करेगी इसकी ये डिफाइन
करने वाला आपको यहां तक क्या करना है
फील्ड मां के चलना है ये है बेसिकली
हायफेंहदी का मतलब और हिफिन अप का मतलब
आपको आई थिंक ओझा आपको समझ में ए गया होगा
दें अपडेट ए रहा है
आप एक कम करना ग्रुप में उसको स्क्रीनशॉट
भेज दीजिए क्या ए रहा है अगर आपका अपडेट
से रिलेटेड जो एरर है तो मैंने क्या बताया
था की लिंक भेजो
दो पेज का ऑफिशल पेज का तो उसके सारे
स्टेप बाय स्टेप परफॉर्म कर लीजिए और आपकी
चली जाएगी क्योंकि जब बिगनर्स होते हैं
सबके साथ यही प्रॉब्लम फेस होती है
सोशलिस्ट वाली क्योंकि आपने क्या होगी की
लाइनेक्स मशीन या तो ओल्ड होगी या आपकी
मशीन उसके साथ क्या है की सही से सेट नहीं
हो का रही थॉट्स ए की आपको वो देखने को
मिल रही है कम कर रहा है सोर्स डॉट लिस्ट
वाली जो फाइल्स है उसको पहले डिलीट करके
उसके बाद क्या करना आपको वहां पर जाना है
जो मैंने लिंक भेजो था ग्रुप में एक बार
फिर मैं दोबारा भी शेर कर दूंगा उसको वहां
से पूरे स्टेप बाय स्टेप लेकिन एक कम पर
फॉलो मत करना उसमें लिखा है
फ्यूचर कभी आपको प्रॉब्लम आया तो वो क्या
कर सकते हो आप फिर से आपको याद रहेगा की
हां मैंने यह स्टेप परफॉर्म किया थे इसका
मतलब ये था वहां जाइए अगर फिर भी नहीं
होता है तो फिर स्क्रीनशॉट के साथ
बिल्कुल
अरे अब तो कट कमांड क्लियर हो गया होगा ना
कस्टमर में कुछ भी नहीं है एक आईफोन सी है
जो करैक्टर के हिसाब से कट करता है जैसे
की हवन सी के मतलब क्या है की उसके लिए
क्या है ये कैरेक्टर है
एक करैक्टर है आई एक करैक्टर है एस एक
करैक्टर है तो c1 मतलब c2 ए सी थ्री एन ये
करेक्ट है और फील्ड का मतलब ये है ये पूरा
फील्ड लेकिन क्या है की उसके लिए आपको
डेलीमिटर देना पड़ेगा दिल्ली मी का मतलब
आपको एक सिंबल देना पड़ेगा मैंने क्या
किया इसको डेटर बना दिया की भैया जहां पर
ये मिले उससे पहले आपको पूरा फूल है अब
उसके बाद ये डेलीमिटर ए गया इसके लिए ये
पूरा फील्ड है अभी यहां पर ये डेलीमिटर ए
गया तो ये इसके लिए फ्रेंड है तो सिंपली
ये है
दें
इसके साथ भी अपडेट की प्रॉब्लम करोगे
नो नो आपको सॉल्व हो जाएगा फिर भी अगर
वाली एरर हो रही है वह सॉल्व हो जाएगी कोई
सुनिए वैसे भी हम आगे बता देंगे एक बार जब
भी आप कैसे पैकेज को इंस्टॉल करते हैं
यानी इंस्टॉल करते हैं वो हम बताएंगे मटका
रेपो वाली प्रॉब्लम के लिए एक बार जो
कॉलेज है इसका जो लिंक है उसको फॉलो कीजिए
और आपका कम हो जाएगा
ये सब के साथ एरर होती है बिगनर के साथ
तो आई हो की किसी को डाउट नहीं है
बात का हम सेशन ओवर कर सकते हैं
बताइए
हम रिक्वेस्ट कर सकते हैं और आप लोगों फिर
से याद दिल देता हूं की आपको लिंक दें पर
जाना है हमारे इंडियन पेज पर जाना है और
इंस्टाग्राम पर पेज पर जाना और वहां पर
क्या करना है आपको बेसिक क्लास अपडेट हो
जाएगी और उसके आपको क्या कमेंट करना है की
आपने जो भी पढ़ा है डब्लू के कमांडो
सीखने को मिल रहा है बाकी लोग आप लोगों से
मोटिवेट हो और हमसे जुड़ने की कोशिश करें
बाय बाय गुड नाइट टेक केयर